enough
enough she pleads in russian
the kremlin says its forces are only
targeting military installations
but in war
there are no such clear lines
[Applause]
this is the result of russian shelling
on the region of donetsk
homes have been destroyed
it's freezing
nothing makes sense
why is nobody saving us why is it like
our kiev city district is cursed
everything has been abandoned here they
were firing at us but we didn't hear a
single shot in that direction who is
protecting us
vladimir putin's war has entered homes
and turned lives upside down
this maternity ward has been moved to a
bomb shelter in the city of kharkiv that
has come under heavy attack
for these new mothers these are
uncertain and terrifying times
above ground people have been
documenting the damage on their mobile
phones
west of the capital cave
what was once an ordinary part of daily
life
is no more
life has come to a standstill in many
parts of the country
many here speak russian have ties to
russia but this war has now become
deeply personal
i don't want to speak russian simply
because putin speaks russian i live here
and my mother is russian and we used to
speak in russian all the time we studied
here and after this after putin attacked
us i deliberately switched to ukrainian
i will speak only ukrainian whatever it
takes
this war is now almost into a full week
with most people here wondering
what is it all for
stephanie decker al jazeera